gabriela recibió un premio en la feria
de ciencias por presentar el proyecto
mejor explicado su trofeo tiene la forma
de una pirámide cuadrangular y está
cubierto por una envoltura dorada esta
es la forma de su trofeo qué cantidad de
envoltura dorada se necesita para cubrir
todo el trofeo incluyendo la base aquí
nos dan algunas dimensiones y queremos
saber la cantidad de envoltura dorada
que estará dada en centímetros cuadrados
así que en realidad vamos a calcular un
área pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo qué cantidad de envoltura
dorada se necesita para cubrir todo el
trofeo muy bien resolvamos los juntos
esencialmente lo que nos están
preguntando es el área de la superficie
de esta pirámide cuadrangular y también
debemos incluir la base porque vamos a
calcular la cantidad de envoltura dorada
que se necesita ahora algunos de ustedes
probablemente puedan pensar en esto solo
con mirar la figura pero para estar
seguros de que no nos falte ninguna área
voy a abrir esta pirámide cuadrangular
para pensar en ella como una figura en 2
así que imaginemos que voy a cortar la
figura por los bordes que voy a cortar
este borde
luego este borde
este borde y este borde los bordes que
conectan los lados triangulares
imaginemos que la voy a abrir como se
vería como se vería si abriera esta
figura bueno en la parte de abajo
tenemos la base cuadrada dejen de
colorear la y ahora voy a dibujar esta
base cuadrada y cuáles son las
dimensiones 3 x 3 y sabemos que es una
pirámide cuadrangular así que en la base
todos los lados miden lo mismo y nos dan
la medida de un lado pero si este mide 3
entonces este también mide 3 también voy
a colorear esto del mismo color para que
identifiquemos que estamos hablando de
la misma base y ahora si abrimos las
caras triangulares como las vamos a ver
bueno se van a ver más o menos así
espero que puedan entender con este
dibujo se va a ver algo así
cada una de estas caras triangulares
tiene la misma área y puedo saber esto
porque todas estas caras tienen una base
que mide 3 y una altura de 6 centímetros
en un momento lo voy a dibujar todas las
alturas miden seis centímetros esta
altura es de 6 centímetros
esta también es de 6 centímetros
esta es de 6 centímetros
y por último esta también mide 6
centímetros así que para encontrar la
cantidad de envoltura dorada que
necesitamos
estamos tratando de calcular el área de
la superficie que en realidad es la suma
del área de todas estas figuras bueno el
área de este cuadrado central es muy
fácil de calcular es igual a tres
centímetros por tres centímetros que es
igual a nueve centímetros cuadrados
ahora cuál es el área de los triángulos
bueno podemos calcular el área de un
triángulo y multiplicarlo por cuatro
porque tenemos cuatro triángulos así que
el área de los triángulos que tenemos
aquí va a ser igual a un medio por la
base que es tres por la altura que es 6
vamos a calcular un medio por 3 por 6 es
igual a un medio por 18 que es igual a
99 centímetros cuadrados entonces cuál
va a ser el área total bueno tenemos el
área de la base cuadrada
más estos cuatro lados que tienen un
área de nueve cada uno así que lo puedo
escribir como 999 más 9 y sólo para
recordarlo este número es el área de una
cara triangular área de una cara
triangular
estas son todas las caras triangulares
y por supuesto le tenemos que sumar el
área de la base cuadrada así que esto es
9 + 9 por 4 o también lo podemos ver
como 9 por 5 que es igual a 45
centímetros cuadrados